>>Erin: There's been a
wonderful real-time change
in the way we're able to
adapt to student needs.
>>Marguerite: What formative
assessment am I using daily,
so that I can measure whether
or not in that class period,
kids are learning the material?
A good Exit Ticket can tell whether
or not a kid has a superficial
understanding of the information,
or has some depth of understanding.
And then the next day the teacher
can differentiate their lesson based
on student needs.
An Exit Ticket is a formative assessment
linked to the objective of the lessons.
>>Shannon: Typically they're
short, just a few questions
and they're focused on
one particular skill.
And we design them ourselves.
They're just what I want to know
if the students mastered
that day in the classroom.
It can also be used to kind
of anticipate something
that you might be working on
for the next day's lesson.
Do they already know it, or
do they know parts of it?
Where can you kind of start your lesson?
>>Marguerite: Some teachers
use Poll Anywhere.
Some teachers utilize a Google form
where kids can enter
in their information.
Then that Google form will
then organize the data
for the teacher into
an Excel spreadsheet.
And some teachers just
use paper and pencil.
>>Shannon: First thing, what's
our number one Exit Ticket?
I just want to know, key points.
What are the best things
that your group came up with?
Your Connections, so historically,
a current events connection.
A connection you made to--
>>Shannon: I just wanted to see
where each group kind of really got
to in their discussion
in terms of depth.
It lets me see which group, if they're
not reaching that level, for example,
that I should spend a lot more time
talking with them and helping them
to develop that, and which groups are
working really well independently.
>>Erin: We use the digital Exit Tickets,
weekly or daily depending on the unit.
>>Shannon: And we purposefully use one,
so every ninth grade
student, we have that data.
>>Erin: We teach the same course,
and we co-plan every single
day's lesson together.
And that gives us a real opportunity
to discuss what our data is showing,
and what do we need to change?
We can use Exit Tickets to focus in on
just understanding one small concept.
For instance, today's Exit Ticket asked
them to identify what elements were
in Persuasion, what elements
were in Argument.
And then we gave them examples
of Pathos, Ethos and Logos.
They had to identify which of those
elements were the most prominent.
So that gave us an idea of whether
or not they could differentiate
between the three.
>>Shannon: So let's talk through our
unit, first let's do Persuasion first.
>>Erin: A lot of them understand
that Logos belongs with Argument,
but they're also lumping
in additional elements.
And I'm definitely seeing that the
entire group needs to review differences
between Argument and Persuasion.
>>Erin: Argument has Logos only.
Today, you're going to be using Logos,
Pathos and Ethos for Persuasion.
And it's important just so you know
there's a different between them.
>>Erin: About Persuasion, I think that's
where we're going to be able to pull
out the students that need just
a little bit more reteaching.
>>Shannon: So clearly like the
text isn't working for them,
so let's do that same visual thing.
>>Erin: I think advertisements
that they're already familiar with,
so that they have a place of
prior knowledge and context.
>>Erin: Logos, Pathos or Ethos?
We're looking at this beautiful
advertisement of Superman.
What is the most prominent
persuasive element you see here?
>>Shannon: Let's have our higher level
groups, since they've demonstrated
through this Exit Ticket that they can
definitely identify those three things
in what they're reading.
Let's move them up to Author's Purpose.
>>Erin: People on the computers in
the back, you'll be watching a video,
and writing a one-paragraph response.
You'll turn it in at
the end of the class.
>>Marguerite: When you
look around the room,
you would think they're all
working on the same activity,
but in actuality, it's
at different levels.
>>Trace: They'll sit down with you,
they'll help you learn the material,
to make sure you get the full grasp
of what we're learning in that class.
>>Shannon: Using data driven
instruction in the classroom in the form
of Exit Ticket, really allows a teacher
to identify each student's strengths
and weaknesses as they're walking
into your classroom every day.
There's no one who's
falling through the cracks.